everything's going you're starting to
make money you're doing something that
you think is good for humanity
and what was the first thing
that you felt
remember all of a sudden after years of
not feeling your gut
your gut comes back into play ironically
and you're feeling something what was
that feeling and what was it
exactly that you're like there's
something [ __ ] here there was a couple
things happening at the same time
um this is way before dos even
people started women who were close to
keith start to get sick from cancer
and die and i thought there was
something in the water
first um i know there was a lot of
industry in that area of albany
um but it also just in two like i
hated going to albany i hated going to
trainings there i like the people i like
the training of themselves but i hated
the whole i felt like
that was something in my intuition that
i managed to to keep away and also away
from
from keith right to never be too close
to him
um so that was my first time i got
really sad like don't they were pushing
me
hard to move to albany like i would i
was never going to get to the next level
if i didn't move to albany
i had to get over my materialism and
that's where the headquarters were
yes in albany in fact alice in mac's
house was in albany
yes she moved to albany i don't know
when
um a couple years after maybe four or
five years
after she joined i don't know but she
was she i mean she moved there
nikki moved there a bunch of people gave
up excuse me their acting careers to
move there
um the other thing this is gonna sound
really silly but one of
the first things that just pissed me off
and i couldn't get over
was um at one of the vanguard weeks
which is the these
birthday celebrations they had was kind
of like summer camp for adults which was
really fun for many years and then it
was really not fun
but um as a as a high rank just me this
is my last year there
uh we promoted people and i was a at
this point i was a green sash
i was one of 12 greens in the whole
company and that was kind of a big deal
and we would present like okay this
person's ready to get to procter and
this person's ready and this person's
ready
and lauren said that um her sister
michelle was ready to go to proctor now
michelle had been a coach the whole 12
years that i'd been there
like she was a coach when i joined and
then i passed her and went way past her
so like she'd been the same level the
whole time
and all she needed to do to get to her
orange was to enroll one person
that's all she needed and i had enrolled
at this point like 100 personally
and all the people 100 people
you've recruited at least a hundred at
least yeah and then the people that
they'd enrolled
like in what's called my organization
was like the imagination right right
people who wrote people there was like
approximately 2 000 people
that started from you that came from my
right my little family
i called them my family right and here's
this other person who just needs one
she's one she's in one so i'm like get
it together i even tried to help her
multiple times because like enrollment
was not
every stripe along the way by the way
required three things your emotional
growth like to get through your issues
um taking certain classes and being able
to teach certain classes and then three
was enrollment
so if you couldn't enroll people you
would never go up
and enrollment was super easy for me
where i got stuck was the emotional
things because they would say well
you're still
whatever control control was my thing
still controlling i'm still controlling
i don't i think that's innate i don't
think that's something that you lose or
do i think that's just a human thing
that some people a little controlling
you you work on it i could be
controlling i could be like
what do you do you just kind of like all
right i'm aware of that oh look the
the picture is a little crooked do i
really need to fix it right now i'm ocd
let's not have control you don't have to
do that you take control of not doing
that that's control
yes you've chosen not to do that
why are my engineers going what the [ __ ]
are you talking about son
are you a control freak michael no i
mean i don't think i'm a control freak
but i i i
certainly i i'm setting my ways a little
bit yeah
and i think that's fine so ultimately
what i came to like post next year was
like
i'm fine the way i am i don't need to
like take all these courses and spend a
lot of money and
needle around in there and just like
accept who i am right i like things
but but wait but so what else so that
was part of the gut thing that you were
feeling okay that's not right you don't
like going to albany
i didn't finish that story anyway lauren
says to me
michelle finally has her enrollment to
get to proctor and i said great we can
enroll a proctor as a big you know
promoter proctor
and she said well she doesn't have the
application people had to sign an
application
to go to a program getting the app and
she didn't have the app yet but we're
gonna promote her anyway like what
the app was the the like the solid thing
that needed i know this sounds so stupid
but you
to answer your question i was like why
are we promoting her if she doesn't have
the app after 12 years
she doesn't have the app then she can't
okay you can't promote somebody on a
verbal yeah yeah i'm taking a five day
you need the paper
to prove it that was always the thing
that was needed for
my entire time there and lauren said
well keith said we can promote her and i
said
he said we can promote her what the [ __ ]
like you can't you can't promote
somebody unless they have the app and i
got
like ver like i got upset i said well
and they said to me
sarah keith decides who gets promoted
there's a lot of people here
getting promoted um who aren't ready
like we promoted you to green and you
weren't totally ready
and i was like what i had my enrollments
like but you hadn't worked through x y
and z but we thought it'd be good for
the whole company to see sarah being
promoted to green like so i didn't earn
my green sash
anyway it was this whole thing where i
realized that the stripe system that i
invested so much into it i thought meant
something meant nothing
and that people were getting promoted
because keith wanted them to
you